you looking forward to that elvis
picture yes very much so there's just so
much history and and you actually got to
speak with priscilla presley yeah that
was really cool that was really
fascinating i found that very
interesting she and elvis maintained a
good relationship even after the divorce
five years into their marriage and she
still oversees the estate and and
protects his name to this day she's very
protective of him she is she is very
much so yeah well i think we're going to
go to jc and talk more about elvis who
is one of the biggest figures in pop
culture history that's right he's over
at the west gate where you can
revisit his las vegas history for the
first time in the release of his new
biopic elvis hi jc
hey mercedes and kendall yes we're
actually in elvis's suite this is inside
the west gate it was the international
hotel back in the day gordon before we
start the tour is elvis's ghost in this
suite because some weird stuff has been
happening to our equipment well you know
this isn't the first time but yeah the
fact that we were running around and
trying to test batteries and microphones
were going on and off it's funny anytime
that thing happened anything happens we
always just like oh well he said it's
the ghost of elvis yeah so this is his
actual suite that we're in where would
this be it's been remodeled but what are
we looking at right now over here so
this was back back when elvis was here
the elvis suite was 5 000 square feet
in the mid 90s the hilton corporation
put up the sky villas up here the
tuscany is now 14 500 square feet but
we're right now standing in what would
have been elvis's bedroom you guys this
is where it would have been where this
is where it would have been this is
where the king this is where the king
would after the shooting this is where
the king would rest right here the
ceiling he would look up the view he
would see absolutely it was different
like you said after you know two shows
so they'd probably be you know a little
bit a little bit worn out yesterday but
he come up here and usually you know
there were other bedrooms down that way
he always had his crew that was with him
they would stay with him uh they would
be hanging out up here you know we hear
from different folks he was really into
martial arts they'd be practicing
karate yes they'd be practicing martial
arts all that type of thing but you know
obviously at that time a 5 000 square
foot penthouse was you know unheard of
it was you know really the the it had
everything all the amenities of its time
and we now have since then uh put the
skyville as in but you know there's
still the presence here i think you know
we joke about the ghost of elvis but
there are things and many people have
said that they feel that presence you
know there's some people that have sworn
they've heard elvis music and there's no
radio on anywhere i believe that when i
walked into the suite i'm not lying you
guys i felt something i felt this power
this energy inside this room and we were
talking too elvis believe it or not he
was he was a germaphobe and you were
saying though elvis is one of the first
ones he always demanded a bottle of
water yeah so there was a gentleman who
worked here and was a steward at the
time and then when he retired was an
executive host he was in charge and he
had to make sure there was always the
refrigerator was always stocked with
bottled water he was very big on that
really before it became a thing always
had to have the bottled water and then
do you know i i'd write this down do you
know what the elvis sandwich is elvis is
classic sandwich you know what it is how
about this it's two slices of bread
peanut butter sliced banana and then
bacon they would make that down there in
the kitchen
yeah oh he got whatever he wanted right
we are talking about we're putting a
special dine like the king experience
together that we want to do in uh a back
dining room in the uh edge steakhouse
which then was the bearing sure um and
we're talking about a menu but we
decided to avoid those types right
with more of a classic dinner i'm going
to set it back here in the studio this
is something very exclusive unless
you're renting the room you're not going
to see the suite but when something is
cool once you walk into the lobby of the
west gate there's that bronze statue of
elvis that was dedicated the year after
he passed away 1978 baron hilton
dedicated that um you know to really
just recognize and pay homage to the
king and his impact not only on the las
vegas hilton but really las vegas
because when you think about it he
really set the tone for you know
everything that's vegas today a seven
year residency a 68 comeback special
launched this residency his career was
kind of done before that 68 comeback
special he says he was walking down the
street in l.a and no one knew who he was
and that's when he realized
i got to do something he's some 30-some
movies does the special starts the rest
residency and the rest is history
absolutely i love it gordon thank you so
much i appreciate it pleasure we'll send
it back to you guys in the studio love
seeing that thanks so much jc and we go
to the king of weather